[Applause]
it's sane actually crazy I am so excited
to see we never get to see each other
really because we both work so hard but
our kids are really close friends yeah
they always wonder when Dylan are and
I'm like they're in a different stage
it's amazing because my kids have no
reference for the fact that she is so
famous and so favors mom they think
Rivers mom that's who
Kelly is and when we were doing song
lane on the lot here yeah there's
pictures of you everywhere and our kids
would just be like what remembers mom's
picture everywhere and where's yours
and where it's yours and I was wondering
this thing are you musical I was the one
white person to of two white people in a
black gospel musical on Broadway but I
didn't have a gospel song for my
audition so I say suddenly Seymour from
Little Shop of Horrors I still got the
job yeah um here's another thing that's
amazing but you're always up for I love
that my crew who is researching you know
like he's up for it where I'm like he's
always up for awards like it's like I'm
sorry when people pull this stuff well
yeah it is so Texas I actually don't
care man well I know you really don't
and people will say like you know it's
nice to be nominated right I'm like give
me the trophy you really don't care it
really doesn't matter to you yeah just
good to be nominated I'll take it I will
take that burden for you
no but you are is it song of the year
for the CMAs yes you met you tied a
record
thank you it's per rainbow for Kacey
Musgraves and um actually one of my
heroes Alan Jackson held the record for
most nominations for song of the year
and I just had that record seven songs
in seven years those kind of things like
not do the whole like you know when when
we're giving compliments or when people
say God's this is amazing
we're so drawn to go oh you know we'll
see I mean how did that happen I'm
trying to say you know what it is
amazing I am so blessed and so truly
honored to get to do what I love and I
know how unusual that is that's exactly
right so I do I just try to go thank you
I am it will happen you stuck with it
you were you were like living in your
car I feel like at one point didn't call
me you were doing I was my sister's
couch I had been in Nashville at that
point for 14 years trying to get a song
recorded and in and out I moved out here
for a while actually when Kelly won
American Idol I had friends that knew
her and I became so obsessed with if I
could just meet Kelly Clarkson I can
give her a song and it would always
happen where they would always hang out
without me and it wasn't intentional the
VIN I was positive at was so certain
that they were like do not bring him
around Kelly and maybe they were I mean
I don't know but but the truth is where
they were all raving about you I even
got and you came to it show where we had
to sit you had to sit in little kids in
Dallas yeah and it like a it was like a
library is so magical you're so great at
what you do thank you such a great
storyteller which is why you have
I need these people with me I'm having a
crowd like respond to you yeah it's it
is wonderful yeah yeah yeah they do in
my head even if they're not here like
when people don't like what I said just
filter it is that was amazing I don't
like talk about song man though because
I remember when this for this idea first
came up the executive editor Audrey was
talking me about it and I thought God is
sister Jean is the whole idea but for
everybody that doesn't know the concept
of song Lena didn't see it like tell
them what the concept is yeah so these
so we have an artist every week and
unknown songwriters are given the
opportunity to pitch songs to these
artists and it sounded in concept like
yeah that's an amazing idea but who
really wants to watch the process that
we all do behind the scenes idea well
the truth is it's been amazing that
people really want to see how did that
song get to John Legend and aunt songs
get there in all different way
absolutely and sometimes they they go I
like that song but it wouldn't work for
me because of this so you have the
opportunity right then to change it for
McLemore and go you know what now
there's room for that how about you know
how about like try this so call it
really is like you're it's a big leap
you know of all those years you talked
about me trying to make it in
songwriting I thought if I could get in
the room with Kelly Clarkson what's
happening is these people aren't getting
in there Emmitt they're getting in the
room with people and so it's really just
getting
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this